[Música]
eu gosto de desenhar o significado das
coisas
isso parece um pouco louco considerando
que a gente está no mundo com tecnologia
onde tudo é tão rápido e eu acabo me
divertindo muito todos os dias
explorando as possibilidades de
significado que as coisas podem ter mas
tudo isso começou dez anos atrás quando
tinha 10 anos de idade quando eu ouvi a
palavra o vestibular pela primeira vez
na minha vida fui perguntar pro meu pai
que era isso aí ele me disse é um teste
que é quando você decide o rumo da sua
vida
aí eu entrei em pânico aí eu falei um
como pra minha vida como como tem um eu
quero muitos têm tantas várias coisas
para se explorar como um só aí a gente
começou a conversar né meu pai tanto o
metal mais daí eu falei tá quais são as
opções que eu tenho então de rumos na
vida né
aí uma opção ficou muito clara as artes
todas elas queria todas e nesse mundo de
artes
eu estava falando com dois pais que são
filhos de imigrantes que fugiram da
guerra para começar a vida no brasil
como agricultores e eles são os
primeiros das famílias deles que
conseguiram estudar e tirar diploma ciné
fazer pós graduação pela primeira vez
eles me direcionaram automaticamente
para a área das artes aplicadas ou como
eu vim a descobrir anos depois a área
criativa
a gente conversou um pouco sobre a
arquitetura mas eu cheguei à conclusão
que a arquitetura era muito concreto pra
mim e eu gosto do mundo abstrato e daí
quando eu falei que não queria fazer
quinteto dura
falei tá quais são as outras opções né e
foi quando ele falou do tal do design e
eu perguntei tá aí o que faz esse tal de
design e ele me disse bom é as pessoas
que desenham cadeiras
aí eu pensei em nosso museu e sóbis em
cadeiras e não é mesmo
ele disse não se você parar para pensar
na verdade elas meio que desejam tudo o
que a gente vê no nosso dia a dia
e foi nessa resposta que eu vi que o
designer o meu caminho então demorou ali
cinco anos para oficialmente sem
apresentada principal desse design foi
na primeira vez que eu fui uma feira de
profissões que eu conheci também um
outro conceito que tem acompanhado muito
nos últimos dez anos da minha vida foi
quando eu conheci o meu primeiro mentor
e foi entre convites para semanas
acadêmicas e ele me emprestando um livro
ou outro da coleção pessoal que ele
tinha que eu fui conhecendo oficialmente
aquele tal daquele design como eu
chamava na época a minha filosofia de
vida vida
o design e me levou pra vários lugares
eu fiz vários projetos nas mais diversas
áreas eu conheci vários tipos de pessoas
e as culturas delas e por incrível que
pareça a viagem mais interessante que o
design me deu não exigiu nenhum tipo de
locomoção de todas as pessoas que eu
conheci e desse contexto é preciso falar
que eu tenho trabalhado com times de 50
nacionalidades diferentes nos únicos nos
últimos dois anos e mesmo assim a pessoa
que eu nunca imaginei conhecer foi a
pessoa que estava ali
entre as idéias do papel em branco
sentada sozinha no chão da minha casa
o heu entre as idéias e o papel em
branco mas no meio disso tudo engraçado
você parar pra pensar que levou dez anos
para voltar para o lugar onde tudo
começou
onde tudo sempre começou pra mim eu
precisei dá tantas e tantas voltas eu
fui para a china trabalha com inovação
social lá e sentei em meio à export de
várias áreas gente tipo muito
interessante e eu me lembro que numa
mesa cujo tema é a agricultura
eu ouvia paa a pergunta que sempre era
pano pra manga e gerava conversa na roda
de chimarrão
o vôo que se você parar pra pensar era
uma pergunta que na verdade é um tipo de
planejamento estratégico por meio de uma
gestão de risco
mas enfim a pergunta era será que a
safra vai dar bom esse ano
e você para mim eu parei pra pensar
muito para escrever se pede eu falei
cara eu precisei morar na selva de
concreto só pra sentir falta das
violetas da minha mãe pela casa
eu precisei viver várias outras culturas
para realmente consegui entender o valor
da minha mas disso elton john na trilha
sonora do rei leão são os ciclos da vida
e eu sei que você até pode pensar mais a
vida dá voltas queridinha
mas a vida continua mesmo eu acho que
quem deu as voltas fui eu
e nessas voltas dentre tantas pessoas
que eu acabei conhecendo foi engraçado
acaba percebendo pontos comuns dentro
desses ciclos da vida entre os meus e os
outros
nisso perceber padrões eu gosto deles e
eu também gosto de perceber
especialmente os padrões invisíveis
se você parar pra pensar o meu papel
como designer estratégica é trabalhar
com esses padrões
pra que essa tradição visual faça com
que essas coisas invisíveis se tornem
mais visíveis para pessoas que às vezes
não lidam com elas todos os dias vou dar
dois exemplos
vocês não acharam que eu sou muito louca
o primeiro deles é aquele business
canvas o antigo plano de negócios que a
gente conhece bem aquele sabe se as
escamas aquele dos quadradinhos que tem
vários quadradinhos que você bota hostis
se você for parar pra pensar aqueles
temas dos quadradinhos e o plano de
negócios é o mesmo conteúdo são os
mesmos tópicos em formatos diferentes
mas a forma como o canvas tratou esse
conteúdo mudou totalmente a sua
experiência com a idealização de um
plano de negócio
um outro exemplo muito simples
era quando estava na escola e se tinha
aquele caderno de tarefas
aquele caderno que sempre tinha que ter
um vídeo da professora aquele caderno
não muda o conhecimento o conhecimento
era o mesmo das discussões de sala de
aula ou dos trabalhos em grupo mas a
forma como você interagir com o
conhecimento fazia toda a diferença no
seu aprendizado não fazia
se você parar pra pensar o meu trabalho
é desenhar essas experiências fazer
completos estranhos trabalharem juntos
um problema comum eu acaba aplicando
isso mais em inovação social em
estratégia e cultura organizacional
mas se você for parar pra pensar uma
habilidade um tanto quanto flexível por
isso que acabou me levando a trabalhar
com tantas áreas e tantos setores mas
foi só quando eu voltei de um
intercâmbio que eu fiz acadêmico que eu
acabei me pegando pensando eu aplico
espera tudo na minha vida - pra mim e
foi nessa exploração junto com uma outra
mentora que surgiu a criar-se um guia
para uma jornada de autoconhecimento a
criar-se é um livro disse que nada mais
é do que uma compilação de coisas que eu
acabei percebendo nos últimos anos e que
eu acho que são interessantes pra gente
se perceber e significa um pouco melhor
para a gente perceber a nossa vida e se
vê com clareza para poder construir em
cima disso mas eu sei que essa coisa
toda de se descobrir de dar significado
para as coisas 25 anos e por mais que eu
escreva ela a cada dois anos
não é o suficiente mas é uma tentativa
uma tentativa que me levou a desenvolver
muito mais do que só um livro o modelo
de negócios
ela me deu um universo inteiro que eu
exploro todos os dias e hoje eu queria
compartilhar um pouco desse universo com
vocês com três perguntas só três
nessas perguntas o que eu vou pedir pra
vocês só é que vocês não pensei em nada
que não seja vocês fiquem bem
confortáveis na presença de vocês agora
e só sentem com essas perguntas
esse pensamento passarem prontos
quais são as três coisas que você mais
valoriza conseguiram pensar nessas
coisas
essas coisas são seus valores
de alguma forma elas representam aquilo
que você realmente acredita como um
valor na sua vida continua pensando
nelas segunda pergunta é como que você
nutre esses valores conseguiram pensar
nas formas que vocês não têm isso todos
os dias ou uma vez por mês uma vez por
ano
essa forma de nutrientes valores
representam as decisões de vocês
agora pense nela um pouquinho
a última pergunta que eu tenho pra
compartilhar é porque é que essas
escolhas são importantes pra você
esses motivos esses porque essa
importância representa o legado de vocês
perguntas três perguntas simples né
mas nem um pouco simplórias perguntas
que pra mim pelo menos representam a
cultura o cultivo o nutri de si mesmo
perguntas que pra mim ajudam a entender
o que a gente está cultivando na vida
se você parar pra pensar o meu trabalho
fazer perguntas que sejam relevantes e
minimamente interessantes para completos
estranhos acharem algum sentido
trabalharem juntos mas foi só com a
criar-se que eu comecei a fazer isso
pensando no ser humano
o indivíduo primeiro porque eu achava
que eu precisava depois porque minha mãe
me pediu depois porque um amigo me pediu
e hoje tá lá e tem gente que vem falar
comigo que eu nem conheço mais
e foi assim que eu comecei a me dê
vivendo a partir da filosofia daquela
filosofia que tinha quando era criança
que hoje me leva a estudar a cultura a
cultura do eu comigo a cultura do eu com
o outro dos meus relacionamentos ea
cultura do desenvolvimento de como a
gente aprende e eu acredito que isso
tenha um pouco me ajudado a entender
essa tal dessa arte de viver
mas afinal como é que a gente cultiva
vida e eu vou compartilhar com vocês um
pouquinho da minha perspectiva do que eu
me vejo no 30 então número 1
eu acho muito importante a gente pensar
no que a gente faz
então o que você faz tudo o que você faz
é uma prática e uma prática já era um
hábito e eu vejo dois tipos de habitats
um que treina eo piloto
um exemplo muito simples que eu posso
dar pra vocês é quando está conversando
com uma pessoa e depois de meia hora
você considera seriamente cuchilla de
tão cansado que você tá e outro exemplo
é quando você está conversando com
alguém e horas e horas se passaram
literalmente e quanto mais o tempo passa
mas você achava que você podia ficar
nessa conversa e eu como uma trena uma
demanda uma demanda maior ea outra de
luta e de forma que você tem muito mais
para dar
quando a gente pensa nas grandes
organizações
isso são chamados de práticas
organizacionais
engraçado né tudo fica mais bonito
organizacional é incrível mas se você
for parar pra pensar uma organização
nada mais é do que a mesma coisa que um
indivíduo é um organismo vivo
agora o número 2
como você faz nutrindo aquilo que a
gente nutre a gente pode nutrir de duas
formas uma é com disciplina pra gente
conseguir criar manter e desconstruir as
coisas
a outra é com consciência e essa
consciência para a gente poder lembrar o
porquê que a gente está criando e
mantendo e desconstruindo coisas no
mundo organizacional
a disciplina é vista como uma tradição
ea consciência vista como disrupção ea
chave de se cultivar a cultura é se
lembrar que para ter uma cultura
saudável você precisa das duas
agora por fim a terceira coisa que eu me
vejo como importante nesse contexto
porque você faz as coisas para viver
viver pra gente poder experimentar de
experiências experiências essas que vão
ajudar a gente aprender e adquirir
conhecimento
coisas novas ea segunda forma é com
sabedoria ea sabedoria justamente pra
gente conseguir extrair significado das
experiências que a gente tem no mundo
organizacional
o aprender é visto como resiliência e
essa resiliência dentro de uma
organização gera aquele senso de
credibilidade eu posso confiar nessa
organização porque por mais que ela r
comigo ela está aprendendo
quando você pensa em significa essa
habilidade de sabedoria de dar
significado para as experiências é
quando a gente vê organizações com valor
de marca que é o que eles chamam em
inglês de bené putin é aquele valor que
não é o valor de quanto vale esse prédio
é o quanto essa marca vale porque ela é
uma marca confiável mas é um mundo de
percepções e essas são as minhas e elas
vão mudar
não porque a gente está num mundo muito
complicado e muito corrido mas se você
for parar para pensar
eu sou de uma geração que cresceu com
tecnologia não porque eu sou milênio ou
empreendedora o nome de digital
mas por que a gente é uma geração de
seres humanos que está havendo uma
realidade que antes a gente só imaginava
nos jacksons realidades que a gente nem
conseguia conceber mas que agora estão
desafiando o cônsul que a gente entende
como futuro do trabalho o
desenvolvimento econômico mundial
tudo muito complicado muito bonito mas
com toda essa tecnologia que pode roubar
empregos o que pode fazer tantas coisas
boas e ruins mas eu me vejo me
perguntando o seguinte se de fato um dia
a gente não precisa mais se preocupar
com o nosso acesso a bens materiais não
porque é de graça mas porque é o de
alguma forma ele se tornou acessível pra
gente
pergunto o seguinte se um dia isso tudo
for possível qual é o significado do
tempo
qual é o significado das nossas
atividades diárias seja trabalho ou seja
outra coisa o que é o significado dos
relacionamentos que a gente chama o trim
do qual é o significado do aprendizado
que a gente está tendo todos os dias
qual é o significado do legado
bom eu gosto de desenhar significado e
eu queria ser artista
mas eu acho que é meio de família essa
coisa de cultivar as coisas esse gosto
pelo cultivar e pensando bem nessa
trajetória toda eu acho que os meus pais
e os meus avós foram os melhores
leitores mesmos porque cultivá
criatividade e esse desenvolvimento de
modelos mentais não é muito difícil não
é muito diferente do que você cultivar
qualquer outra coisa exige tempo
presença e intenção ou pelo menos é isso
que eu tenho visto no treino nos últimos
anos e se desenhar tem levado a explorar
coisas que tem me deixado cada vez mais
intrigada pra ver o futuro e pra
perceber essa filosofia que a arte de
viver e eu não sei o que vocês têm
implantado mas eu quero muito saber e aí
vai dar bom esse ano
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]